ne vous inquiétez pas c'est juste mr.  Dean, je veux dire, si
Chiron avait quelque chose à faire, alors oh
tu es tellement foutu
quoi que ce soit que tu penses que je l'ai fait je ne l'ai pas
fait tu n'as rien fait Percy exactement
comme tu sais que tu es censé être
le seul de Poséidon ouais ouais alors  il
semblerait donc que la croyance ait été tenue par erreur,
tenez bon, vous dites que la personne a un
frère ou une sœur
oh saint Styx un autre Poséidon un flou
pas exactement techniquement Tyson n'est pas un
sang-mêlé les sang-mêlé sont à moitié humains d'
où le  nom je ne comprends pas si ces
nouveaux enfants ne sont pas à moitié humains mais après la moitié
est-ce qu'il nymphe l'a vu et quand il a croisé
une divinité avec une nymphe
c'est c'est un Tremayne diversifié c'est fait
salut salut frère